CYNTHIA THOMAS: Hi,
this is Cynthia Thomas.
I'm a networking
specialist at Google Cloud.
Welcome back to What's
New in Networking.
Today, we'll focus on edge
and security-related launches.
Stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
First, let's talk about Cloud
Armor Managed Protection Plus.
This is a service that packages
DDoS protection, Cloud Armor
WAF functionality, and future
protection capabilities
into an enterprise-friendly
subscription.
Managed protection aims
to simplify Cloud Armor
deployments, reduce
management overhead,
and minimize financial risk.
Cloud Armor Managed
Protection Plus subscribers
will also have access to
additional value-add services,
including adaptive
protection, named IP lists,
and other future services.
Well, the future is now, and
we have some exciting additions
to Cloud Armor Managed
Protection Plus.
Introducing DDoS response
and bill protection services.
With DDoS response,
customers can get help
with analyzing and mitigating
ongoing DDoS attacks.
Customers with premium
support have the opportunity
to engage DDoS response
services and get access
to SRE and engineering teams
that are responsible for DoS
protection for all of Google.
Customers who suffered
from a DDoS attack
may see an increase in
their infrastructure bill.
With bill protection on
the covered resources,
you can now open a claim
with billing support
and receive credits
for the amount
of the spike, provided that the
attack was sufficiently large.
Now, onto more
security launches.
Until now, you couldn't
deploy firewall rules
at an organization
or folder level.
Now you can, with hierarchical
firewall policies.
With hierarchical
firewall policies,
security admins can
define and enforce
firewall rules at the
organization and folder levels
in the GCP resource hierarchy.
Firewall policies make
rules management easier.
Policies contain
multiple firewall rules
that are attachable to an
organization or folder.
Hierarchical firewalls
enable automatic protection
for new projects and networks.
It also allows flexible
firewall configurations required
for complex cloud environments.
Next is a super exciting feature
that just went GA, secure data
exchange for VPC
Service Controls.
VPC Service Controls is a
key differentiator for GCP
and works to prevent
data exfiltration.
With secure data
exchange, you now
have more fine-grained
controls on the data exchanged,
down to the method and
organization level.
For example, you can
enable your partners
to have read-only
access to a GCS bucket
from a different organization.
Finally, we're
excited to announce
the general availability
of request coalescing,
often known as
collapsing, for Cloud CDN.
Request coalescing collapses
multiple user-driven cache flow
requests for the same cache
key into a single origin
request per edge node.
We have already been applying
this behavior on purpose
since last year, but now, this
is the default for all request
types.
Request coalescing is
now the default behavior
for all new and existing
Cloud CDN customers,
benefiting from a reduced
load on the origin.
And that's what's
new in networking
for edge and security.
Let us know your thoughts
on these new features
in the comments below.
Check out the links for more
info on how to use them,
and join us next time to
learn more about what's
new in networking.
[MUSIC PLAYING]